if he respects you you should have to
file a sexual harassment case very soon
you guys in relationship you're married
right here
you're not who are you
just
friends for what bruh
you this age you got two female platonic
friends
are you married
divorced and then you were like let me
just have the same thing without sex can
you imagine being like no i can't handle
this marriage anymore man i just want to
get out there find other women and hang
out
can you imagine an existence where
you're like no bruh i don't get to just
be friends with other women i can't do
this anymore i want a divorce
i want to have conversations with other
[ __ ]
not you guys sorry hypothetical women
not you guys at all don't take that the
wrong way that's not you don't think
that's a little bit weird hanging out
with this guy if you know whoever
[ __ ] loobies or whatever he's getting
his discount no i got the ride covered
don't worry about it and then a [ __ ]
bus pulls up
what the hell is wrong with you dude
that's being single right there this guy
that's drinking too much already you
that didn't want to be here i know that
motherfucker's single he not happy but
at least is with his homie
you not happy and then you're just
adding more unhappiness on to it you
gotta give a [ __ ] about her stories with
no incentive
there's nothing at the end of that
conversation for you just more
conversation that's crazy you're an old
man dude get out there and [ __ ]
something you got divorced to not [ __ ] i
don't understand this at all i'm upset
about your life right now
jerry literally people say that as a
figure of speech no the way you live in
your life bothers me dawg i'm your life
coach for the next 45 minutes [ __ ] the
show
the show will happen you need to get it
together we can't have this [ __ ] you got
kids
buddy live your [ __ ] life
there's no rain dragging you down and i
love kids i want kids you need to either
have more male friends or a kid one of
those two just start nutting in women
left and right and see what happens
you're bound to catch a young one you
know what i mean leave her some money
get a little anna nicole smith situation
going you're a worker you're a
hard-working guy and now you're just
adding more work female friendship is
work dawg they have emotions did you
know that [ __ ] they have emotions and
you gotta deal with that you know men
don't have emotions we bury everything
and then we punch a hole in a wall we
act like nothing happened that's male
[ __ ] it's simple it's straightforward
you are doing community service right
now and you don't even know it
are you on parole dog what happened
is your wife a judge this is your
punishment
this is part of the divorce settlement
no no i don't want him to be happy you
can keep his money but i want to take
his happiness from him
so he has to hang out with other women
with no opportunity for sex at the end
of it buddy you're 62. you know what you
need horse
literal [ __ ] pay for it i don't care i
can't [ __ ] fathom and i can't wrap my
mind around it it bothers me
you are better than him you don't
deserve to be [ __ ] treated like this
by some guy not even trying to have sex
with you that's disrespectful
can you believe that [ __ ] what kind of
man would it hang out with you this much
and not try to have sex with your
attractive women you don't see that this
[ __ ] guy if he respects you he'll try
to have sex with at least one of you
if he's a real feminist both of you
that's a feminist
that's a feminist right there
i can't [ __ ] believe this guy yo
i can't [ __ ] believe this guy
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
[Music]